richard clarida subdirector de la
reserva federal de eeuu presentó su
renuncia al presidente vaivén tras las
investigaciones de corrupción que lo
acusan de insight training es decir de
invertir y transar en la bolsa de nueva
york- con información confidencial
privilegiada de movimientos que hizo la
reserva federal para dinamizar la
economía en eeuu concretamente claridad
retiró dinero de un fondo de acciones
cuando los mercados estaban a la baja
por cuenta de la pandemia y volvió a
invertirlo en ese mismo fondo días antes
de que la reserva federal anunciara
medidas para reactivar la economía y los
mercados financieros
la renuncia de claridad viene después de
la renuncia de robert kaplan y erika
rosenberg que dirigían las oficinas de
la reserva federal en boston y dallas
por hacer maniobras similares con
información privilegiada como una
epidemia ética y legal en los niveles
más altos de la reserva federal así
califican algunos activistas
entre tanto joan power director de la
reserva federal asistió hoy a su
audiencia de confirmación en el comité
bancario del senado para asumir su
segundo mandato a cargo de la fecha
powell había sido inicialmente nombrado
en el cargo por el ex presidente don
otro